توقع محافظ البنك المركزي التونسي ان
ترتفع نسبه التضخم في مستوى قياسي جديد
الى 11% خلال عام 2023 مؤكدا ان اغلب
المؤشرات الاقتصاديه سلبيه وتفرد اصلاحات
ضروريه ورغم دعوات محليه ودوليه للحوار
يستمر الانسداد السياسي في البلاد على وقع
دعوات سياسيه المعارضه واخرى نقابيه الى
تحركات الاحتجاجيه في المستقبل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الاسباب التي ادت
الى تفاقم الازمه الاقتصاديه في تونس وهل
من واجهه لربطها بانسداد الافق السياسي
الذي تمر به البلاد وما مدى تاثيرها
بعوامل خارجيه ما هي الخطه خطه تونسي
والحكومه لتجاوز الازمات الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه في ظل الاضطرابات العماليه
ودعوه المعارضه الى احتجاجات شعبيه مطلع
الاسبوع المقبل وهل لدى المعارضه برنامج
سياسييا وخارطه تاريخ لاخراج البلاد من
الازمه وما هي فرصها الحاله الجنسيه
وتحسين الظروف المعيشيه التونسيين عبر
جلوسي مختلفه الاطراف الى طاوله الحوار
[موسيقى]
الازمه الاقتصاديه ماضيه نحو التفاؤكم
اكثر منظره التونسيين بعام اقصى سيثقل
اوضاعهم المعاشيه واقتصاده بلادهم بنسبه
القياسيه اعلى من التضخم هناك ما اكده
محافظ البنك المركزيه التونسي مروان
العباسي مشددا على ان الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
في البلاد ستكون صعبه اذا لم يتم الاتفاق
مع صندوق النقد الدولي وفيما يبدو محاوله
احتواء الاحتقان الاجتماعي اكدت رئيسه
الحكومه التونسيه نجلاء بدر خلال لقائها
على امين العام لاتحاد الشغل ورئيس
الاتحاد الاعراف على ضروره تنقيه المناخات
العامه والعمل المشترك لايجاد الحلول
الملائمه
وبين تشدد ومرونه تصدر بين حين واخر
تصريحات عن الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد فقد
قال ان تونس تتسعوا للجميع لكنه في
المقابل نفع ان تكون هناك ازمه متهمه
للمعارضه بالاستثمار في الحديث عنها
وداعيا الى ضروره تطهير الدوله من من قال
انهم استولوا على مقدراتها رافضا اي تهديد
للسم الاهلي والاجتماعيه في البلاد
وعلى الواقع انتخابات سياسيه وحقوقيه
لممارسات السلطات التونسيه دعت جهات
المعارضه الى تحركات الاحتجاجيه في
المستقبل القريب بينها جبهه الخلاص
الوطنيه التي اعلن رئيسها احمد نجيب
الشابي الدعوه الى تنظيم مظاهره في شارع
الحبيب بورقيبه وسط العاصمه بالتزامن مع
ذكر الثوره التونسيه في الرابعه عشر من
شهر يناير
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا موضوع محمد ذويب الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي وعصام الشابي الامين
العام للحزب الجمهوري اهلا وسهلا بكم سيد
محمد
ما هي الاسباب التي ادت الى تفاقم الوضع
الاقتصادي وهل من وجهها لربطها مع انسداد
الافق السياسي في البلد
اهلا بك هي الازمه في تونس متقدمه ومن
المتوقع ان تتفق مع اكثر خلال السنه
القادمه بطبيعه الحاله الازمه لها ثلاث
اسباب رئيسيه هي او الاسباب هي مخلفات
العشريه السوداء ال السابقه التي كانت
ثقيله على تونس وعلى التونسيين وخلفت
مقارنه بارقام ثقيله مقارنه حتى بما كان
يحققه النظام بالعريقه قبل 14 في 2011
ايضا السبب الثاني هو الازمه العالميه
ومخلفات وماكرون وخاصه ما يجري فوق رانيا
والازمه والسبب الثالث هو التعاطي ال- ال-
ال- الذي لم يرتقي الى مستوى الطلعه
التونسيين حكومه تشربودا خاصه في المساله
اقتصاديه وفشلها في حال العديد
يعني انت لا تحمل الرئيس سعيد اي مشكله في
ما يحدث وهو صاحب مراسيم القرارات كلها
وطبعا المعارضه تقول انه يقود الولاده الى
كارثه
انا عندما ذكرت حكومه السيد للاجنبي حكومه
السيد النجم
بودانها السيد قيس سعيد قيس سعيد اذا
يتحمل مسؤوليه الحكومه الازمه مركبه
والهاء ثلاث اسباب رئيسي كمان الشباب
الاول هو مخالفات العشر سنوات السابقه
بسبب الثاني
مع المسائل الاقتصاديه المهمه خاصه على
مستوى بعض الوزارات خاصه تلك المتعلقه
التجاره والصناعه
والتريدهم
وفلاحه وغيرها هذه تقريبا الاسباب
الرئيسيه التي همم هي اخرتها الوضع الذي
يعيش في تونس
يعني باختصار من فضلك هل تعتقد ان هناك
رجاها في ربطها بموضوع الانسداد في الافق
السياسي في البلاد
سيد ذويب هذا السؤال لك باختصار لو سمحت
ولكن بالنسبه للحزام التي حكمت خلال
العشريه البارده لا يمكن لها بطبيعه الحال
طالما انها كانت جزء من المشكله ان توفر
الحل ولكن هذا لا يعطي رئيس الجمهوريه من
واجبي في تغيير توجيهي السياسي العام خاصه
في مستوى الحوار مع بعض الاحزاب التي لم
تتورط خلال العشريه او بعض او خاصه مع
المنظمات الوطنيه الاتحاد العام التونسي
الشغل والاتحاد الصناعه والتجاره والرابط
الوطني
بعض الكفاءات الاخرى التي تعيش فيها تونس
سوف فتح رئيس الجمهوريه مصر العربيه
مده ربما
[موسيقى]
طيب طيب
هل ترى هذا الامر اييه مقنع ان هناك اسباب
عديده لموضوع تدهور او تفاقم الازمه
الاقتصاديه وهي ازمه عالميه يتحمل الحكومه
جزء من المسؤوليه ولكن هي ازمه عالميه في
حقيقه الامر
اعتقد فعلا ان الوضع الاقتصادي في تونس
صعب وان الاسباب عديده ومتعدده ومعقده
هناك اخفاق في اداره الملف الاقتصادي منذ
ثوره الى اليوم وكنا نعاني من ازمه حاده
على مستوى اداء الحكومه السابقه لكن هذه
الازمه فاقلبت وانتقلنا الى حافه الانهيار
الاقتصادي بفضل الاداره الغريبه والفريده
للسيد قيس سعيد واضعافه لمؤسسه الدوله
وعدم قدرته على الميم بالمعطيه الاقتصاديه
في الاقتصادي وفقدانه اليه رؤيه او توجهه
لانعاش الاقتصاد او اصلاحها وهذا مما ادى
اليوم الى ان الدوله التونسيه اصبحت على
حافه الافلاس نحن في مفتتح هذه السنه بادر
في اليوم الثاني من شهر جانفي يعني منذ
يومين عاشت تونس على اضرابا في قطاع
الحيوي هو قطاع النقل نتيجه عدم قدره
المؤسس العموميه على السنه الهجريه العمال
وهناك عديده القطاعات الاخرى اليوم
تتهيا لخوض نيزالات واضرابات للمطالبه
بتحسين اوضاحها والمطالبه
بمستحقاتها الماديه والاجتماعيه فضلا عن
ذلك اليوم كما اعلن محافظ البنك المركزي
تونس تتهددها مخاطر ماليه جلديه وحقيقيه
ومره اخرى السيد سعيد وحكومته همم يعني في
شبه غيبوبه هذا الوضع يريدون التعليق كل
فشلهم واخفاقهم في اداره الشان السياسي
والاقتصادي على معرضهم وعلى الحكومه
السابقه بين اليوم تونس تدخل لاول مره منذ
عقود طويله الى نسبه تضخم برقمين وهناك
البنك المركزي اليوم مضطر للمره الثالثه
في سنه واحده الى الترفيه في نسبه الفائده
البنك المركزي يدل على ان هناك شفافيه
بالنسبه لهذه همم الارقام هذا واحد الشيء
الاخر هل ترى ان هناك
من اي منطقه في ان يربط موضوع الازمه
الاقتصاديه بتعثر الجانب السياسي المسار
السياسي في تونس
اولد يعني الارقام اعتقد ان هناك شفافيه
في الطعايه من الارقام وان محافظ البنك
المركزي اداء اراد اليوم ان يخلي مسؤوليته
من تدهور الاوضاع ومزيد تدهورها والقى
بالمسؤوليه على الحكومه ولا السيد وهناك
لهم خلاف بين محافظ البنك المركزي وزير
الاقتصاد الذي انتقد قرار الترفيه في نسبه
الفائده المديريه وهناك ارتباط وثيق بين
انسداد الوضع السياسي وهمم اضعاف لمؤسسه
الدوله وغيابه تشاركيه والحوار الاستنبات
الحلول وعدم تشريك القدرات والخبرات
التونسيه في السنبات الحلول اضافه الى
فقدان الحكومه ومنظومه الحكم في تونس
منظومه الانقلاب لاي مصداقيه في الطاعات
السيد محمد يقول لك
عفوا نفتقد الى مصادر
الدوله وليس هناك في الافق اي طيب همم ااا
برمجه للحوار مجددا في الجانب السياسي
على الوضع الاقتصادي بالجانب السياسي يقول
ضيفنا محمد ذويب هناك من يؤيده بانه
الاحزاب التي حكمت كما قال في العشريه
الماضيه ليس من حقها ان ان تلقي باللائمه
على قيس سعيد ووو ولن يكون لها دور ايجابي
في المرحله المقبله هو عليه ان يغير
توجهها السياسي في ربما الحديث لاثره في
اخرى ولكن ليست هذه الاحزاب بالتحديد هل
تعتقد ان هذا همم امر ايجابي
هذا خطاب لم يعد صديقه احد من التونسيين
يعني خطاب اقصائي يريد ان يقصد جزء من
التونسيين في
الحوار وفي التعاون على تجاوز الصعوبات
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والسياسيه في
بلادنا هذا هو سبب البليه اليوم السيد قيس
سعيد اقصى الجميع وهو اليوم ينفرد منذ
اكثر من عام ونصف بكل السلطات ولم يكون
بمقدوره تحريك او تحسين اي من الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه يا سيدي اليوم
المعارضه
والمنكلون بالتونسيين كما يصفهم السيد
خارج دائره القرار ما الذي فعله السيد
يعني اسال السيد محمد الذوي بهذا السؤال
وساعوده اليك ما الذي فعله قيس سعيد سعيد
هي الخروج من الازمه همم هل له مسار خطبه
واضحه للخروج من الازمه الاقتصاديه او حتى
السياسيه
كما قلت لك لم تحسن التعاطي مع الوضع
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي بطبيعه الحال
هوايه تتحمل جزء من المسؤوليه لكن
بامكانها بامكانها لم اتخذت قرارات اكثر
جراه ان تقوم بجمله من الاصلاحات مثلا في
مستوى الوضع الجبائي في مستوى مقاومه
التهريب في فتح الملفات القضائيه وخاصه
القضايا الفساد في الملف في عديد الملفات
التي ضل تقريبا هذه القضايا البطوره
مكانها منذ سنوات ايضا همم تحسين
المفاوضات مع صندوق النقد الدولي وتقديم
الحلول ايضا تحسين المفاوضات مع الاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل وتقديم تقنيات كل هذا
بامكاني ان يقدم حلول اذا ارادت حكومه
تجربودا ان تقوم بذلك اضافه الى انه على
رئاسه الحكومه مثلا الغاء استقلاليه البنك
المركزي التونسي وهو اخطر قرار تقريبا
اخطر قرارات التي اخذتها البرلمانات
السابقه لانه همم المؤثر
سياده الدوله هناك عديد الحلول وعلى
الحدود ولكن مره اخرى اعود اقول لا تع هذا
الامر يرتبط بالجانب السياسي وهو دائما
يلقي باللائمه على اطراف لا يسميها دائما
يتحدث عن جهات مجهوله يتهممها دون ان تكون
هناك شفافيه دون ان يكون هناك نقاش على
الخطط التي تنتهيجها الحكومه اعتماد فقط
على قرض من الصندوق النقد الدولي في غياب
في الحقيقه
للشفافيه في هذا الموضوع
قيس سعيد بطبيعه الحال يا اخي خطاب قيس
سعيد لم يرتقي الى مستوى خاصه في مستواها
من الخصوم دون فتح الملفات القضائيه التي
يعرف التونسيين انا عديد الاحذيه مثلا
المتورطه خليل العشريه الفارطه في عديد
القضايا السياسيه وبعض الصفقات العموميه
والتفسير وغيرها ولكن خطاب قيس سعيد كان
في ولد وطموحات تونسيه في وادي الاخر ايضا
المساله القضائيه ظلت هي التي تعرق مسار
الاصلاح في تونس ومحاسبه الذين افسده
واطلاق يد الابرياء لانه ليست كل المعارضه
فاسده كما يروج قيس سعيد قيس سعيد له خطاب
غير لم يرتقي الى مستوى همم الى مستوى
الوضع السياسي والاقتصادي والى المستوى
الوضع الديمقراطي في تونس خلال هذه
المرحله
في الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل الكبرى
المنظمات النخابيه في تونس تاكدوا ان
المنظمه بصدد التشاور اطلاق مبادره انقاذ
في ظل ازمه خانقه تشهدها البلاد في
المنظمه اك خلال مجلس الجهوي في مدينه
القيروان ان الاتحاد بدا مشاورات مع هيئه
المحامين والرابطه التونسيه للدفاع عن
حقوق الانسان مشيره الى ان الهدف منها هو
التوصل الى بلوره مبادره تخرج بلاده من
ازمتها عبر خريطه طريق واضحه واكدت تلك
القيادات ان المنظمه النقابيه لن تتخذ
جهدا في هذا الاتجاه وستقدم المقترحات
وسوف تقدم
بدء لانقاذ السيد عصام الشامي همم
اليس من باب المزايده مطالبه الرئيس سعيد
بخطه في وضع ماذون لهذه همم الدرجه وما
جدو المرور اللي هي الحل السهل هو اتهامه
والقيام بتحركات احتجاجيه
اذا لم نطالب السيد قيس سعيد بالمبادره
باصلاح الوضع والتراجع عن كل الخطوات التي
ادرت بالبلاد واضعفتها واوصلتها الى حافه
الانهيار والهويه فمن الذي يصنع طالبها
اليوم المبادئ الذي تفضلت بالحديث عنها
التي اطلقها الاتحاد العام تونسي شغل
بمعيه بعض المنظمات الوطنيه هو الدليل على
فقدان الثقه في قدره رئيس الجمهوريه الذي
يجسد الدوله ويحتكر كل السلطات على اطلاق
مثل هذا الحوار الذي تحتاجه تونس وطلبنا
به منذ اكثر من من عامين رئيس الجمهوريه
لا يقبل الحوار
ليس مدرج اعماله وبالتالي هو الطريق
الوحيد امامه وهو ممارسه الهروب الى
الامام تونس تواجه التحديات والصعوبات
كبيره هو يريد شماعه يعلق عليها كل
اخفاقاته شماعي يعلق عليه بكل الفشل الذي
يراكمه منذ استيلائه واحتكاره للسلطات
وانقلاب يعني الدستور وعلى الشرعيه
الدستوريه اليوم المنظمه الوطنيه قامت في
مبادره محموده للبحث لان اليوم لا يمكن
لكل وطني في تونس ان يبقى مكتوف الايدي
وان نبقى في موقع المتفرج على انهيار
بلادنا لقدر الله اليوم الاحزاب السياسيه
الشخصيات الوطنيه قاده الراي العام في
تونس مطلوب منهم وهم الان بصدد تكثيف
المشاورات لاطلاق عده مبادرات ان تلتقي
التونسيين للجلوس على
الاتفاق على خريطه طريق لانقاذ البلاد لكن
مع الاسف واذا مؤكده ان السيد سعيد هو
العقد في وجه الاخلاق
سيد محمد ذويب ان الرئيس سعيد هو عقب
تحديدا همم لعوامل كثيره ولكن اهمها انه
يرفض الحوار كل هذه القوى السياسيه تريد
ان تجلس في الحوار لتشارك في الخروج من
الازمه
وفي غياب خطه موجوده لدى الرئيس قيس سعيد
ورفض تام للحوار
[موسيقى]
الصناعه والتجاره واتحاد
القبول من رئيس الجمهوريه قيس سعيد وهذا
ما نتمناه خاصه
عموما التي اتحاد العام التونسي مؤسسه
وازنه في تونس وتاريخيا كانت لها نظاراتها
وكانت لها مواقفه ولكن عليه ان يوضح ايضا
شروط هذا الحوار وان يوضح النقاط وان يوضح
ايضا مخرجات هذه الحوار وطبيعته لان
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل شارك في 2014
في حوار وطني ولكن لم يؤدي الى شيء فقط
ادى اثر ذلك الى لقاء باريس بين حركه
النهضه تونس واغلقت وفقه عديد الملفات على
غرار التسفير والاغتيرات السياسيه
والارهاب
وخاصه هجوم بعض الميليشيات على مقر
الاتحاد العتروس الشغل يوم الاربعاء
ديسمبر 2013 مبادره الاتحاد العام التونسي
لشغل والمنظمات الاخرى مبادره محموده
ونتمنى ان تجددا لدى رئيس الجمهوريه
ونتمنى ان تمثل انطلاقه حقيقيه باتجاه
تونسي
يقولون ان الرئيس ليس لديه خطه ولكن هل
للمعارضه خطه في ظل الانقسامات واضحه في
صفوف المعارضه وحتى الحضور الجماهيري فرقه
اللي ان اا يضغط ذلك الضغط الكبير على
رئيس الجمهوريه
اولا بالفعل للمعارضه اليوم هي معارضه
تتفق في الهدف في معارضه نهج الانقلاب
واضعاف مؤسسه الدوله وتطالب بارسال الحوار
الوطني كمخرج واا وحيد من هذه الازمه
لكنها اليوم هذه المعارضه ما زالت مشتته
وتشقها خلافات وزير الخلافات لا تمنع من
انها تلعب دورا في تكثيف الضغط على السلطه
لحملها على تراجع على كل الخطوات التي
ادرت باستقرار البلاد وتهدد مستقبلها
اليوم المعارضه كل المعارضه تعتقد انها
تهيئ نفسها للضغط ورفع نسق الضغط الشعبي
والجماهيري بمناسبه احياء ذكرى انتصار
ثوره الحريه والكرامه واليوم نحن في الحزب
الجمهوري وفي الاحزاب الديمقراطيه في
الخماسي همم اطلقنا هذا المساء نداء
التونسي للنزول بكثافه الى شارع الثوره
شارع حبيب برج ايفا يوم 14 جانفي وجعله
يوم وطنيا لدحر الانقلاب اسقاطه
تحت رايه الوحده الوطنيه
منقسمه على نفسها ولا تقبل اطرافها الحوار
مع بعضها البعض فكيف لها ان تطلب في
البقاع بل الحوار من من رئيس قيس سعيد
لا يمكن ان ترفض المعادله الحوار مع بعضها
البعث هذا اللي يستقيم من يطلب الحوار
والحوار الوطني في طريق للحل لابد ان يكون
اول من يتهيا واول من يقبل بالاخرين
بالجلوس على الحوار هذا المطلوب من من
المعازه انا اعتقد وانا اعتقد نحن في
الحزب الجمهوري هذا المعارض عليه ان تغير
مناسك طاعتها السياسيه مع الازمه ان تنتقل
من مرحله المنطقه الحوار الوطني الى
الجلوس على مائده الحوار والى ان تتفق على
برنامج وطني للانقاذ وتتفق على خريطه
الطريق للضغط تنفيذ هذا البرنامج تونس في
حاجه الى حكومه تونس اليوم ليست لديه
حكومه هناك حكومه سوريه بيقدر رئيس
الجمهوريه تنفذته وليست لها اي قدره على
اداره
الدوله التونسيه تونس في حاجه الى
استراحات سياسيه وفي حاجه الى العوده الى
الشرعيه الدستوريه الى الدستور شكرا
والعوده الى الانتخابات
رئاسيه وبرلمانيه السابقه لاوينها تعيد
مؤسسه الدوله توازنه وعافيتها لكي تواجه
شكرا
مع الاشقاء والاصدقاء شكرا
كذلك محمد ذويب الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
كان معنا من تونس
ما وراء الخبر
[موسيقى]